i'll tell you what i've been watching
rent's a girlfriend yeah
that is is that a guilty pleasure i
don't know if that's a guilty pleasure
i i i genuinely think it's like the best
show this season i think it's a really
good show
really it's the best show of the season
though gone i mean three zeros
yeah we've said it three zero head and
shoulders above the rest oh yeah
okay yeah the last episode have you
watched the last episode yeah oh my god
i was crying like a [ __ ] baby like
research
we're getting to reserve in a minute but
rent a girlfriend
that is just why does it work because
it's such a generic harem plot right i
hate the watch
[Music]
because i read the synopsis of that i'm
like this seems
really unsilly like no it it seems like
it's made for insole
like the protagonist is a living bra
moment
every every every time he does something
i'm like for [ __ ] sake why
why are you doing this bruh seriously
bruh
nah bro the problem is right no now this
anime comes out people can be like well
we can we should actually make this a
thing and they're going to be like we
should do this this is normal we should
normalize this
yeah normalize paying goals but we
already do that with uh online
yeah they're gaming yeah yeah yeah gg or
something whatever it is surprised i'm
surprised you're enjoying it though
considering
it's really fun i mean i hate the main
main character and i i saw when you
tweeted out saying like oh
he's irredeemable they're people like no
oh he's not irredeemable
you know it's like bro he's annoying as
[ __ ] the insult like protecting their
boy
i i i know it's probably like the uh the
manga readers who's like well he hit he
gets character
sure he will yeah yeah which which i'm
looking forward to seeing him become a
better person
but right now i can't remember why i
called him i think it was like uh
like it comes from a protagonist
which is so accurate it's so accurate
he's gonna come stand
the way i view him is like i i [ __ ]
hate bakugou from my hero academia yeah
everyone [ __ ] loves him and i'm like
he's a piece of [ __ ] yeah he's so
selfish i don't get it yeah yeah
why are you people like why why are you
booing me i'm right like
yeah because i think that's the thing
that really pissed me off which just
would just how selfish he was
and his self he he was he is
ridiculously selfish and like
if if you're one of those people who
like relate to him
no no because it's the people who like
related to subaru in the start it's like
what's wrong with you yeah it's it's
it's like okay like
if you are my mate and you were hacked
and you were acting like him
i would i would i would have like i
would need a talking tv
yeah i would i would have to talk to you
you would catch these hands yeah yeah
yeah exactly
because i i the person who i liked the
most wasn't him but he was his best mate
yeah like he was a true bro who like who
was looking out for him and everything
and so far the main protagonist hasn't
done anything that's made that's made me
feel like
man he deserves best girl man he
deserves his bros
so i'm like i'm looking forward to
seeing his character development which i
assume is what happens still in the
manga
or it's the manga okay being the
mongoose if this was [ __ ] that happened
in real life you and this was in like
your friend groups you'd never be
forgiven i'm doing this
no you would absolutely be clown on by
yeah so he like rents a girlfriend
she's great you know i mean yeah
spoilers for like first three episodes
and you know this girl that dumped him
he immediately gets back with her even
though she's talking [ __ ] about him
in front of his friend and it's like
what are you what what
i can't believe this [ __ ] this is like
this is where you would be like wow this
guy's my friend
yeah this is what you would be like no
no no i'm friends with an absolute
can't right yeah selfish [ __ ] yeah
oh my god and like it's it's one of the
first haram anime where there's clearly
a best girl because
she's a [ __ ] girl of the season she's
such a she's my pvp
mvp and she's coming through yeah she's
not only like helping them out she's
like
with the grand situation oh my god
like i'm [ __ ] cheering but at the
same time i kind of don't want to cheer
as well because
cheering means that she she has to end
up with this person at the moment
at the moment and it's it's so hard to
like be like
go protagonist i hope she gets like a
giga chad just to make skin cells
in cells mad i want incels mad bro
man i've seen the incel takes on twitter
man i think
they get me [ __ ] fuming oh my god you
guys have never left your room like
is this your first like haram anime that
you've been following then
uh weekly oh because because harem anime
don't really seem like a thing you would
watch yeah that's the way i was
that's why i was surprised when i heard
you were watching it um i mean i
normally watch them but i think because
they make life so difficult for
themselves it's so frustrating to watch
it's like you're you don't you didn't
have to make this difficult you like you
made your life [ __ ]
yeah you could have spoke to her but you
[ __ ] sat there like okay
one thing that you would never do in
real life right if your girlfriend
whatever walks off
even if it's your rental girlfriend yeah
you go after her yeah yeah yeah that's a
universal thing like even
like idiots yeah people who are the most
nervous people on earth and shy
they go after the posters yeah yeah yeah
yeah and if they don't your friends will
immediately be like yo
dude go yeah yeah yeah like like the
thing that pissed me off is
like in a lot of these situations his
friends are acting like
his friends should act they're like bro
get get you go get
a go and he's getting angry that they
don't know the full situation even
though he's put himself in this
situation
go after the girl if she storms out
angry that's like rule number one
exactly even if it's a fake girlfriend i
would still go go after my girl
you know yeah exactly the reason why i
might i don't think i like harams is
because like maybe in my head i'm like
i'm trying to speedrun it in my mind i'm
like
what would i do for optimal strats to
get real like no no no no you did the
wrong route here
you just lost 20 seconds you know what i
mean well yeah but i think but i think
that's the problem right is like you're
trying to like
watch these kinds of shows to relate to
like well
you're basically if we're relating it's
like speed runs right like you're trying
to be like all right how am i going to
speedrun this while watching 100
run what it is it's like why aren't they
taking the optimal route
not knowing that they're trying to do a
high